i am here off the coast of Panama where
we just recovered what we believe to be
the coffin of legendary Explorer Sir
Francis Drake who is buried at sea over
400 years ago are you sure you want to
be defiling your ancestors remains like
that you make it sound so dirty besides
thought you didn't believe me well I did
do my research and apparently Francis
Drake didn't have any children well
history can't be wrong enough for
example you can't defile an empty coffin
ahh you devil what is it come on hold it
up hello no no no a deal was for a
coffin that's it wait a minute if my
show hadn't have funded this edition you
wouldn't about your story lady look mr.
Drake you signed a contract I have a
right to sell every single thing that
you hold that thought Sully we got some
trouble hurry it up okay okay what's
going on uh pirates pirates yeah the
modern kind they don't take prisoners
Lisa male prisoner me what are you
talking about uh shouldn't we call the
authorities or something yeah that would
be a great idea if we don't exactly have
a perfect to bigger what yeah so unless
you want to end up in a Panamanian jail
we should probably handle this ourselves
well what's worse you obviously haven't
been in a Panamanian jail do you know
here's one of these ah yeah it's like a
camera you just point and shoot right
good girl here we go
how the hell they find us out here these
guys have been telling me for weeks
thought I lost him these guys don't like
you much do they bus talking for
shooting
yup Sally
oh no you don't
gonna be solely now
good
sully where are you
logging
Jamie
rocket monster
okay that's not good
Wow
my security
we gonna jump
are you doing okay
come on go
I can't leave you alone for a minute can
I I had everything under control until
they blew off the ball you all right
nothing that yours a therapy won't fix
well if it isn't the beautiful and
talented Elena Fisher flattery will get
you screen time yeah more
behind-the-scenes kind of guy Victor
Sullivan huh for chrissakes what do you
say we get out of here before we attract
any more attention
well little present from Sir Francis
above so you found the carbon wait a
minute is this what I figured it Drake's
lost diary he faked his death just like
I said Sully he must have been onto
something big yeah well let's just keep
that between us
mr. Drake I think over go look at that
diary when we land
so luck when Drake sailed into the
Pacific he took the Spanish fleet
completely by surprise he captured their
ships he took all their maps their
letters their journals and he recorded
everything in this diary uh-huh so but
when he got back to England Queen
Elizabeth confiscated all of his charts
and log books including this one and
then swore his entire crew to sign yeah
so Lucy Drake discovered something on
that voyage selling something so secret
and so valuable they couldn't risk it
getting out all right Nate just pretend
for a minute that I don't really care
about any of that stuff and cut to the
chase would you man only interested in
the climax it must be a real hit with
the ladies never had any complaints ok
then I'll jump to the good part just for
you oh hell goddamn Dorado he was on to
something big all right does it say
anything else oh so now you're
interested huh yeah well unfortunately
no last page was torn out I'm telling
you Sully this is it this is finally it
yeah only we got one little problem yes
that's what I said it blew up it's
saying
no that's why we have insurance right
oh oh no the camera no the camera is
fine don't worry about the camera still
as good as new Sully the girl can hold
their own you should have seen her fine
you go on out there and you tell her we
just found the lost city of gold maybe
her producer can get it on the answer
come on Nate do you trust me more or
less good cuz we're gonna have every
two-bit scumbag and the World Racing us
to this treasure unless we cut her loose
right now you're a real gentleman Sully
I know it stinks she'll get over it no i
don't i don't care for over budget I
mean do you realize that this could be
like the biggest story of the year hi no
I don't trust him okay that's why we
need to move fast so just get me the
camera crew and I promise you that
should have seen that one coming